الان سنتناول ملف اعتقد انه يهم اي شخص
لديه كمبيوتر او يستعمل اي تطبيقات مثل
جوجل او غيرها للبحث هذا موضوع
مثير جدا هو برنامج يثير الدهشه والخوف في
الوقت ذاته ويتعلق الامر ببرنامج شات جي
بي تي يوفر امكانيه مخاطبه هائله مع
المستخدمين
يتحدث مع
المستخدمين على مدار الايام الماضيه
انتشرت المئات من اللقطات تظهر مجموعه من
النقاشات مع روبوت المحادثات
جي بي تي الذي كان يتحدث في كل المواضيع
تقريبا
وجيزه المستخدمون عبروا عن دهشتهم الى ما
وصلت اليه قدرات
هذا التطبيق على النقاش والاجابه على
الاسئله
والكتابه بدقه شديده حتى انه يمكن مثلا ان
يسرد ابياتا من الشعر مقالات دراسيه حتى
بعض النكات يعني هو كل الجوجل لكنه متحدث
يعني
نعم الهدف من هذا الهدف من هذا المشروع هو
محاوله جعل التحدث باستخدام الذكاء
الاصطناعي يبدو اكثر ثلاثه وطبيعيه مثل ما
تبدو المحادثات بين البشر اذا يمكن
للمستخدمين طرحه اسئلته على الروبوت
وسيجيبوهم عن تلك الاسئله بجمل كامله
الان ينضم الينا من كاليفورنيا محمد العلي
مهندس الذكاء الاصطناعي وتحليل البيانات
اهلا وسهلا بك استاذ محمد في الواقع لدي
مليون سؤال وسؤال اريد ان اسالك عن هذا
التطبيق يعني في ملايين الاشخاص يحاولون
الان
يسجل يعني يستخدم هذا التطبيق ولكنهم على
قائمه الانتظار خلال اسبوع اصبح لدى هذا
التطبيق اكثر من مليون شخص ما هذا الهوث
يعني هذه التطبيقات
ما الذي يميز هذا التطبيق تحديدا لهذه
الدرجه
اولا شكرا جزيلا على الاستضافه اذا تسمح
لي قبل قبل ما نتحدث انه كيف يميز هذا
الشات جي بي تي عن بقيه التطبيقات خلينا
نوضح للمشاهده انه بصوره مبسطه انه كيف
يعمل
بشر اللي هو عباره عن تكس نكتب التاكس
فمثلا كمثال انه انا اكتب لانه
التطبيق راح يسوي سيجمانتي يقسم
الجمله تبعي الى الى عده اقسام بعدين خلي
تاج لها علامه انه هذا مثلا هذا فعل هذا
الناون وبعدين يحاول يوجد انه انت تيجي
مشهور مثلا
وهكذا بعدين انه يتحول الى فاكتر ويسوي
ويوزن الكلمه شنو المعنى يريح يعرف شنو
المستخدمه يريد الاجابه فيسوي واي يوزن
يوزن لليبولز اللي اللي ادخلناها الي
وبعدين اكو ال الاجابه تكون عن طريق همم
عذرا الاجابه تكون عن طريق انه انه همم
بريتش ريند ذاتها مدربه مسبقا اتغذت الى
هذا التطبيق عن طريق الويب سايتات عن طريق
الارض كروز عن طريق الكتب عن طريق الروبوت
تبعتها او القتال
وضافه شيء جديد هذا الاوبل على البقيه انه
يحتوي
انه يحاول انه يمنع انه يكون ورود او ريسس
بالموضوع
انا يعني مررت جمله في في اثناء
التقديم انه مثل جوجل ولكن
متحدث يعني هل هذا صحيح بمعنى انه سيجيبك
على السؤال وفقا لما لقنا من بيانات
ومعلومات فاذا لقينا بيانات ومعلومات
خاطئه سيكون الجواب خطا
من الذي يضمن هنا من الذي يضمن هنا صحه
تلك المعلومات التي
سيقدمها لنا هذا الروبوت
المشكله في ال في التطبيقات السابقه ان
كثير من المعلومات تكون بعضها صحيح يحتمل
الخطا هذا ما الذي يجعلنا نعتقد انه اذكى
طبعا 100% اذا نرجع اذا نرجع على الصفحه
الرئيسيه تبعت شادي
هم اصلا
انه احنا ممكن نقدم فورميشن معلومات غير
صحيحه ممكن نقدم
يعني ممكن نقدم معلومات انه مؤذيه
بالاضافه الى يقول اللي مدهشه تبعنا انه
احنا الايفنت اي احداث بعد 2020 ما عندنا
احداث ما عندنا معلومات صحيحه اجابه صحيحه
بالاضافه الى ان هو بايظ اعطيكم مثال همم
همم يعني هذا اشخاص اذا كتبوا انه مثلا
كيف اوجد افضل ديتا ساينس مثلا
عمر المبرمج لازم يكون مثلا خلينا نقول
بالثلاثين لازم يكون لون البشره تبع ابيض
وهكذا هاي مشاكل طبعا ويا اي تطبيق ممكن
ينزل جديد ممكن يصير هاي المشاكل ولهذا
احنا لو لاحظ انه انه مو فقط اوبن اي اي
عندها همم
كابوات كابتن همم مايكروسوفت نزلت بال
ويخلق فرص عمل للاشخاص مثلا كمثال انه همم
نشوف الناس اللي نسوي برودكت ديسكربشن
يسووا وصف على على اي برودك او منتج
ويسوون شارج على 100$ و150$ قام ويستخدمون
على
يوفر لهم البروتك سكربشن بالاضافه الى
احنا مو بس شركه اوبن اي يعني
احنا ممكن
نقدم تيكست نكتب كلام نقول مثلا نريد صوره
صوره مثلا
مال كره السله تبعها
يوفر لنا صوره ما منها مثيل طبعا موقع
اشهر موقع
يقدم صور للبيع وصور مجانا
خلى انه كان من ضمن استخداماته
اللي هي ترسم او تسوي صور تبعها
يعني
اكثر الناس المتحمسين لهذا التطبيق هم
الطلاب والاكاديميين لانه التطبيق يفترض
انه يوفر لهم افضل دراسات بطريقه جدا
ومنهجه ومنظمه بحيث ممكن يقدمها يعني باحث
يقدمها ويكون يعني افضل بحث هذا يضع سؤال
كبير بالنسبه لتقييم هذه الابحاث من جانب
الاكاديميين والمدرسين يعني بمعنى اخر كيف
يميز الطالب اذا كان عنده القدره انه يحصل
على افضل دراسه ممكن بس بكبسه زر
صحيح هذا الكلام طبعا ما حد يقدر يميز هذا
الموضوع غير غير قابل يعني ما ممكن انه
شخص يميز انه هذا الدراسه
بس احنا نتحدث عن موضوع اخلاقي مثلا
اعطيكم مثال همم كنت في حلقه مناقشه مع
باطره
الناتج
هذول الاشخاص هم محاضرين في جامعات
بالاضافه الى عندهم اوبن بروجيكت اوبن
سورس بروجيكت لاحظوا انه يكتبون شيء في في
يسالون على كود
مشابهه
يعني مختصر جدا
هل يمكن للمستخدم
نفسه ان يزود التطبيق بمعلومات يعني هل
يستفيد التطبيق من معلومات المستخدمين ام
لدي قناه واحده هي اداره التطبيق هي التي
تعطيه المعلومات
سؤال جيد جدا
كل ما انه شخص يستخدم
ههه شكرا جزيلا لك محمد علي من كاليفورنيا
اشكرك